we all know Detroit's in trouble a
bankrupt city full of crumbling houses
abandoned factory buildings and a fast
dwindling population but while the
politicians unions and investors slug it
out in bankruptcy court and grasp for
their share of what little cash the city
has left ordinary citizens are left to
make do in a city with no functioning
government this is what happens when
people are left to their own devices
this is anarchy in Detroit
it's like a biker gang but lawnmowers
gang colors you know you can't buy this
t-shirt you have to earn it
Tom Nardone started the mower gang once
the city stopped maintaining its parks
but back then it wasn't really a gang it
was just him with a mower I was
surprised when the first person showed
up I couldn't believe it I guess someone
else's as crazy as I am when they closed
them they don't put a wall up around the
place they just stop caring they stop
mowing you know some West rapper here is
stolen all the chain-link top of this
place and now they just stop coming
around I care about little kids and I
think they should be given an
opportunity and a place to play and if
their parents and the government that
they've elected can't accomplish that
then maybe someone should step in and
fortunately you know myself and a lot of
these other guys have the financial
wherewithal to do that if you've ever
read democracy in America de Tocqueville
addresses this issue in some detail and
very well he talks about Americans are
always forever forming these
associations to put together resources
not only in terms of financial resources
but in terms of talent resources to make
their community their city their state a
better place and I think that's part of
our cultural capital here whether it's
in Ishpeming Michigan Detroit Michigan
Los Angeles New York that sort of thing
you have a lot of people with that that
rich tradition behind them they know it
and want to be part of it we don't
accomplish that much I mean we keep 10
parks in a four-state of repair the city
when it operated properly kept 300 parks
in great shape while the mower gang
can't save Detroit or even Detroit
Sparks by itself it is but one example
of private citizens working together to
make Detroit a better place
you
you